why are you doing this you had been
ranked in our top 40 scream queens in
korail's
so demonstrate a good scream for me
today oh gosh okay let's see Mike uh-uh
no my thing for me gotta really get in
the diaphragm got really push it out
there to pretend like you're doing that
guttural scream or that horror movie you
know shriek when you were in the box it
just took it to a whole dolly not
unrealistic though cuz I'm severely
claustrophobic so that was truly Khloe
screaming really to get out of the box I
was like the biggest challenge of
growing up in the spotlight well yeah I
mean it's been 13 years now and I think
you know the biggest thing is is just
trying to continue to outweigh the the
pros from the cons you know as many
things as there's been with being in the
spotlight I've also had the ability to
have a really wonderful platform and now
such a massive breadth of fans that have
grown with me and that I feel like I
know personally in a lot of ways and
that is is a is a massive opportunity
and and to also kind of jump out a film
and and use it you know in in my human
rights activism and and going to the
more political side of it is been a
massive coup for me like ask Louis
Francis yeah I mean I've admired Khloe's
work for years you know I mean she's
actually she's gonna work as it's the
age of age she was amazing as a kid
actor almost like a Jodie Foster kind of
character you know everyone needs a
friend
between more than friends
we're connected
this could happen to anyone and I know a
lot of celebrities talk about you know
the stands that they encountered have
you experienced anyone that has made you
the subject of their obsession yeah I
mean I don't want to highlight too much
the reality of the situations that you
know we sadly kind of find ourselves in
as public figures but yeah yeah I know
I've been into the reality of it and
it's it's pretty brutal but to be able
to depict it with Isabel who pair you
know part of me wanted to be like not
too unhappy about this build-a-bear
stopping me because he's one of the
coolest most prolific actresses of our
time yeah so doing this with her was
nothing short of of a dream it just
makes me think that you have to kind of
change your mind about the way that you
handle strangers after watching this
film I mean yeah it changed the way that
you deal with strangers and good deeds
that you do for others well it's the
thing is you know maybe I would have
returned the wallet before if I found it
on the street and nowadays if I found a
purse or a wallet I don't think I would
yeah
makes me think twice for helping the old
lady across the street want it not the
old lady now you have you never know you
really do you never know but one thing I
found so interesting about this film is
that it is female-led it's in all of the
main roles I mean was that a special
piece for you in this film
well definitely it subverted the genre
it took the Anthony Hopkins character
and cast Isabel who parrots at the
boyfriend character and she was Michael
Monroe to be my best friend and by doing
that it takes a story that we love and
you know gets butts in the seats so
watch a fun story but it inspires you
and it feels innovative and exciting by
subverting it and making it modern and
that was a chance for me which felt like
that's a step forward in the industry
that we need to take
[Music]